this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer in our quest for
clean and cheap energy massive solar and
wind firms have sprung up across the
world investment in these renewable
resources reached two hundred and
seventy three billion dollars in 2018
included the eight previous years and
that figure reaches two point three
trillion dollars this is positive news
for most but money have been left asking
why not nuclear after a quick
examination of country's carbon dioxide
output per kilowatt hour of energy
produced it becomes clear that countries
like France are currently doing better
than countries like Germany in the quest
to produce low-carbon energy
France with 61% of its electricity
generation from nuclear is producing
just 32 grams of carbon dioxide for
every kilowatt hour produced where
Germany a country that has invested
billions into wind and is gradually
closing down all its nuclear power
plants and replacing them with natural
gas plants and wind energy is producing
318 grams of carbon dioxide for every
kilowatt hour it's perfectly
understandable why many advocate for
nuclear energy over renewables wind
itself releases less carbon dioxide for
every kilowatt hour of energy it
produces at about 11 grams just under
nucleus 12 grams per kilowatt hour both
because wind is intermittent it needs to
be propped up by some form of power
production that can quickly ramp up and
produce electricity when the wind falls
a natural gas is the perfect solution
for that at a reasonable price so in
reality wind isn't competing against
nuclear energy at least not directly
it's competing with larger baseload
power stations like natural gas and to
see why it's losing that battle we need
to dive into the world of economics to
see why countries and investors are
showing nuclear energy when choosing
where to invest money in infrastructure
there are several factors you need to
consider risk potential gain and the
time it will take to get a return on
investment are the most important
this is an extremely simplified example
of a return on investment calculation
for two power plants a 1,000 megawatt
nuclear power plant and a 1,000 megawatt
natural gas power plant this calculation
is based on the wonderful video on the
illinois energy professor youtube
channel which i will link in the
description below when making this kind
of calculation we have a few variables
we need to consider the cost of
construction the fuel cost and the
construction time are the biggest
variables that differ between the two
energy sources the average cost of
construction for a nuclear power plant
is a difficult number to pin down the
number varies widely from project to
project ranging from five thousand five
hundred per kilowatt to eight thousand
one hundred per kilowatt we will assume
a lower price of six thousand per
kilowatt resulting in a price tag of six
billion for a 1,000 megawatt nuclear
power plant natural gas on the other
hand is one of the cheapest types of
power plants to construct with a cost of
about nine hundred and twenty dollars
per kilowatt so a 1,000 megawatt power
plant would cost 0.92 billion but let's
just run that up to 1 billion for
simplicity sake now I know you already
see the problem
natural gas is just cheaper and it's
going to take the nuclear power plant
longer to recoup that cost this becomes
even more of a hare and tortoise race as
a result of the construction time of
each the average nuclear power plant
takes six years to construct whereas
your typical natural gas power plant
takes about two years to construct this
becomes a particular issue when
borrowing and interest rates are
involved we are going to assume an
interest rate of 3% and a repayment term
of 25 years for both plants and both
will borrow in 1 billion dollar
increments one billion dollars on a
twenty five year repayment plan at a
three percent interest rate equates to a
fifty six point seven million dollar
payment every year here we will borrow
an idea from the Illinois energy
professor and illustrate profit and loss
with
it's below the x-axis these blocks
represent debt above the line they
represent profits we will place
nuclear's profit and loss on the left
side of the graph and natural gases on
the rice each full block unit like this
represents fifty six point seven million
dollars these blocks can be partially
filled to represent smaller fractions we
are using this to bring the vast
quantities of money involved into a more
human scale let's begin in the first
year of construction both plants will
generate one unit of loss as both
borrowed 1 billion in the second year
the nuclear power plant borrows another
billion so it now owes the bank double
the repayment so it now has a total of 3
units of loss natural gas does not
borrow another billion so it just needs
to pay off the current one unit of dead
Oh dearly for a total of two the natural
gas plant is now complete it took two
years it can now begin to generate
revenue to turn that loss into a profit
now we need to calculate revenue both
our 1,000 megawatt facilities meaning if
they both run for an hour they will both
generate 1,000 megawatt hours of energy
calculating revenue from this number is
not straightforward as the energy
marketplace is complex grid operators
may buy a large percentage of nuclear's
base load out in advance for a set price
as it can turn itself off easily it
needs to continually run an electricity
prices drop in the middle of the night
as demand Falls energy prices constantly
fluctuate so it makes sense for nuclear
power plants and the grid operators to
agree on a bulk price whereas the
natural gas plants can operate as
peaking plants shutting down during the
night and only operating during the
evening when electricity demand and
prices are at their peak allowing them
to fetch a better price for their
electricity thereby losing less money on
operation and maintenance of their plant
and getting the maximum profit out of
their fuel spent factor in transmission
costs as energy is lost to power lines
taxes and all the other messy factors
and it becomes even more difficult to
calculate earning figures this
calculation will be inaccurate
we will make a massive assumption and
assume they will both earn the same
amount at 525 million a year after all
these deductions are made so in its
third year the natural gas plant will
have a revenue of nine and a quarter of
these blocks after our loan repayment
that will be eight and a quarter blocks
of profit but there is another large
deduction we need to consider that
differs greatly between these power
plants fuel costs here nuclear has one
big leg up its fuel is relatively cheap
just by virtue of only needing a very
small amount in comparison to natural
gas a single uranium fuel palace with a
diameter of an AAA battery has the
potential to release the same amount of
energy as one tonne of coal or half a
tonne of natural gas a little goes a
long way to run the 1,000 megawatt
facility for an entire year you would
need about 64 million dollars worth of
fuel or 1.1 currency blocks to produce
the same amount of electricity the
natural gas facility would need about
450 million dollars worth of fuel or 7.9
currency blocks these prices will also
fluctuate but again this calculation is
simply for illustrative purposes so once
up and running the nuclear power plant
can produce more electricity for less
money factoring that in the natural gas
plant will make five hundred and twenty
five million dollars of revenue deduct
both loan payments and fuel costs and we
are left with about one third of our
currency units of profit on to year
three the nuclear power plant borrows
another billion and so now owes three
units of loan payments for a total of
six in loss the natural gas plant
however makes one-third of a unit which
is removed from our loss year for the
nuclear power plant borrows another
billion and adds four units of loss the
natural gas plant removes another
one-third of a block ear five nuclear
borrows another billion and adds five
units of loss the natural gas plant
removes another one-third of a block
year six nuclear borrows its final
billion and adds six units of loss the
natural gas plant removes another
one-third of a unit
mainly the nuclear power plant is
finished and will begin generating
revenue in year 7 deducting the loan
payments and fuel costs leaves us with
two point two units of profits even with
the huge loan repayments which will be
paid off completely in 24 years the
nuclear power plant is making fare more
profit per year but it has a long way to
go in reversing this loss year 7 year
ace the natural gas plant has now broken
even your 9 year 10 year 11 year 12 year
13 here 14 year 15 years 16 the nuclear
power plant has now broken even and even
made a profit you're 17 you're 18 you're
19
you're 20 okay you get the picture over
the long term the nuclear power plant is
insanely profitable but the risk
involved in reaching the profit is huge
politicians and investors alike are
hesitant to put their money on the line
when six years in there is 1.2 billion
dollars of loan repayments made with no
revenue on the books with the first six
years of loan repayments alone you could
have built another natural gas plant
that's insane did the company take out
another loan to pay for the loan
payments financing these things is
difficult getting that money from
politicians is hard too because most
politicians aren't going to think about
long-term energy strategy because
something that won't start producing
electricity for six years and won't turn
a profit for 16 is not in their interest
they will need to be voted back into
office before then factor in that
nuclear power plants have a terrible
track record for running not only over
budget but over time resulting in an
even larger run into negative before
revenue begins a nuclear energy just
becomes a really difficult investment to
justify that's why they are falling out
of favor before even discussing the
safety issues looking at these numbers
you would never expect a nuclear power
plant operator to decide to shut an
operational plant down yes that's
exactly what's happening in many places
take the Diablo Canyon power plant in
California this power plant is run by
Pacific Gas and Electric a company with
a diverse portfolio of energy generation
hydroelectric nuclear natural gas and
renewables they are an investor owned
and publicly traded company maximizing
profit is their prerogative yes they
have decided to close down the Diablo
Canyon nuclear power plant in 2024 when
its 40-year license expires why would
they do that
well that's complicated first in order
to renew their license they needed to
modernize the entire facility at a cost
they deemed too high they needed to
change their cooling system from a once
through system where sea water is pumped
through the facility for cooling and
dumped back into the sea to a closed
cycle evaporative cooling system which
used the same volume of water
continually and thus reduced
environmental impact one particularly
large cost was the cost of integrating
appropriate earthquake protection after
lessons learned from the Fukushima
disaster where tsunami flood water
destroyed emergency generators and
caused three separate meltdowns and
three hydrogen explosions as much as
nuclear advocates want to say nuclear is
safe which it can be making it safe is
expensive PG and E themselves said the
retrofit was too expensive and instead
decided to shut the entire plant down
they decided it would make more economic
sense to close this facility and replace
it with renewables this says a lot about
nuclear energy economics when even an
existing plant can't compete it's not
just nuclear energy that is facing
competition three hours north of Diablo
Canyon natural gas turbines were retired
and replaced by battery storage that's
because California is producing so much
excess solar energy that buying it and
storing it in batteries to sell later
makes economic sense the energy America
place is a complex machine and no
one-size-fits-all approach can be used
we can get a clearer picture of these
costs with an analysis method called
levelized cost of electricity or LCOE
the levelized cost of electricity
attempts to give a simple comparable
number that represents the cost a power
plant will need to charge for a unit of
energy in order to recoup its cost over
the course of its lifetime the equation
looks like this but putting it simply
it's the
of costs over the lifetime of the plant
divided by the total quantity of
electricity that plant will generate and
sell in its lifetime here we can see
that onshore wind photovoltaic solar
power and combined cycle natural gas are
by far the cheapest forms of electricity
and this is the real reason they are
gaining larger market shares for nuclear
to rise to prominence once again it
needs to evolve it needs to compete with
the role natural gas is filling it needs
to be smaller cheaper and safer ideally
the reactor should be dispatchable
meaning it can turn itself on and off so
it can fit neatly into modern grids with
high percentages of renewables that's a
difficult problem to solve but people
are working on potential solutions that
could make nuclear energy competitive
once again we will discuss some of these
solutions in future videos every 45
minutes as much energy falls on Earth's
surface as all of mankind uses in a year
we now have a way to capture that energy
efficiently now we just need a way to
fulfill our energy needs at night
ensuring those in power make the right
decisions requires voters who understand
the energy market and solar technology
platforms a good place to start is
brilliant excellent course on solar
energy it teaches you how much energy is
available to extract from sunlight based
on where you are and the composition of
the atmosphere then you'll learn the
thermodynamics and semiconductor
concepts that enable the two main kinds
of solar energy platforms solar thermal
power and photovoltaic cells by the end
of the course you'll have a solid grasp
on the relevant physics and a clear
picture of how light beaming from the
Sun ends up as an electrical current
streaming in your device this is just
one of many courses on brilliant that
will improve your ability to understand
the world around you you can set a goal
to improve yourself and then work on
that goal a little bit every day
brilliant makes that easy with
interactive explorations and a mobile
app that you can take with you wherever
you are if you are naturally curious
want to build your problem-solving
skills or need to develop confidence in
your analyst
abilities then get brilliant premium to
learn something new every day
brilliant thought-provoking math science
and computer science content helps guide
you to mastery by taking complex
concepts and breaking them up into
bite-sized understandable chunks you'll
start by having fun with their
interactive explorations and over time
you'll be amazed at what you can
accomplish as always thanks for watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Twitter
Instagram discord server and subreddit
Ereb below
[Music]
you